[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias
[Música]
es probable
además de una persona
que sean del ejército
y por compartir
la posibilidad de que el día
para poder hacer eso quisiera compartir
contigo algo muy importante
dirigí a otras personas
con permiso
o la sigue pasando por un momento
difícil
por favor desde este momento deja de
sacar la historia mientras desastre
hace dos años y hoy desde estudiar
los géneros ya sean iguales y comprender
exactamente todo
pero quiero que sepas que he vivido las
excepciones en las vías de tranquilidad
ningún asentamiento
así
y esa ciudad
la seguridad
tiempo y sin presentar hechos
[Música]
pero la solución
ayuda
después
se caía
y por eso la ayuda profesional y por eso
el dolor
nuestra sáfina no solamente tú no sabes
alegre
[Música]
y si se suelta encontrarán soluciones y
debe seguir adelante
por eso todos
cuatro simples pasos
carlos todas esas ideas las realizan y
de amigos
y relevantes
[Música]
por esto
el sistema de presión
estamos alertas porque si nos echamos lo
mejor que podemos hacer es celebrar
y yo
una formal
con esa sola pregunta podemos presentar
la comunicación de llevar a la persona y
eso nos permite
y este
es muy efectiva y además es muchísimo
por cada persona
qué felices 1600 represivos personas
jóvenes 39
y ya
[Música]
y
y por qué
dejando
nuestra suerte
desde señalamiento costaría el shot la
legación
la guía la depresión la vergüenza el
dolor
de hecho es
a pesar de que no puede existir
y un mensaje para la verdad
por qué
hubo momentos de creciente saber unir
abandonarme debe ser las siguientes
el más hermoso
y
y cerebrales y corazones pensamientos y
deliberante
estas personas decidió entonces
un antes y un después para aceptar una
procesa
bastante profesional
buenos y días malos y ese recuerdo
siguiera su misma intensidad
pero la estrella
y mucho
sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]